okay so what exactly is the case against
trump when it comes down to it the case
against trump is just that trump is a
big bad orange man who's very bad in
orange
like the lincoln project cut what i
think is the single funniest dad i have
ever seen in my entire life yesterday
this ad sums up all of liberal feeling
it's a lincoln project first of all
just kudos i mean really just all sorts
of props on being the greatest grift i
have ever seen it's an incredible gift
because the lincoln project you will
recall was begun
by a bunch of former republican
strategists who couldn't make money
in republican politics anymore and
decided they were not just anti-trump
they were anti-the entire republican
party that's how you know it's a grift
it is one thing to say you don't like
trump and you don't want to see him in
the white house
it is another thing to say that susan
collins needs to lose her senate race
because you don't like donald trump
but that's what the lincoln project has
done so the lincoln project has raised
tens of millions of dollars tens of
millions of dollars
from democrats because democrats think
oh these are our converts these are
these are people who who have decided to
leave trump behind
and they're gonna lead the fight here
okay five seconds if donald trump
is not in office anymore the lincoln
project will be tossed on the side of
the road like a used condom they'll be
done
right no one's gonna care about these
people no one's gonna like them no one's
gonna care about them
they'll go back to being you know tepid
republican racists
in five seconds flat but they they are
cutting some pretty amusing ads and
paying themselves lots of money to do so
so here is an ad they cut against trump
this is their closing ad
against trump in the waning days of the
election
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a mother walking into her sleeping
child
hey honey
you asked me to wake you and tell you
what happened in the election
who won
trump trump won
but i thought you could only be
president two times
[Applause]
not anymore
[Laughter]
[Applause]
stop it more it will never stop hold
about oh my god
that ad sorry
that's some funny bleep right there so
the lincoln projects pitch
is that if you don't stop trump now he's
gonna be president forever
forever i just want to point out
there's only one president in american
history who served more than two terms
it was fdr there's a democrat that's
when they uh that's when they passed a
constitutional amendment saying that you
could only serve
two terms not sure exactly how the
lincoln project thinks that trump
uh will continue to serve after two
terms but apparently that is the great
fear they don't
even have to make a case against trump
they're just that that's some funny
stuff
right there facts don't care about your
feelings and it's a fact that the ben
shapiro show is the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content